خارج نوافذ قمرة القيادة ،
يرى الطيارون المحاربون المخضرمون في البحرية الأشياء التي تفاجئهم على ما يبدو ،
هناك أسطول كامل من النظرة على سا ،
يا إلهي ، نحن جميعًا نواجه
الريح ، وعقدة الريح التي تبلغ 120 عقدة ،
هذا الفيديو من
مهمة تدريب عسكرية أمريكية قبالة الساحل  في
جاكسونفيل فلوريدا في عام
2015. الأشياء هي الأجسام الغريبة
وقد رأى الطيارون العسكريون الأمريكيون
الكثير منها في السنوات الأخيرة لدرجة أن
البنتاغون ومجتمع المخابرات الأمريكي
قد أجروا تحقيقًا واسع النطاق
الليلة علم CNN
أن مسؤولي المخابرات لم يعثروا على
أي دليل على  تأكد من أن هذه
الأشياء هي مركبات فضائية غريبة
ولكنهم لا يستطيعون أيضًا استبعاد
هذا الاحتمال وفقًا لخمسة
مصادر مطلعة على تقرير قادم
للكونغرس ،
هناك الكثير مما لا يمكنهم قول الكثير
لا يعرفونه من وجهة نظر علمية
ولكن قد يكون هناك أيضًا  قضايا التصنيف
في السنوات الأخيرة تحدثت CNN إلى
طيارين سابقين في البحرية لم يتمكنوا من شرح
الأشياء التي رأوها على trai  بعثات نينغ ، كان رايان
جيفز الذي طار
طائرات مقاتلة من طراز FA-18 سوبر هورنت
في نفس المهمة قبالة جاكسونفيل التي
رصدت هذه
المقابر ، أخبرنا أن هذا الكائن كان مشابهًا
لما رآه في مهام تدريبية قبالة
الساحل الجنوبي لفرجينيا
طوال عامي 2014 و 2015.
قال إن الأجسام أظهرت
القدرة على البقاء في الجو لفترات طويلة
ويمكن أن تتحرك بشكل جانبي سريعًا الآن في
كثير من المرات سنحلق حول
هذه الكائنات
وتميل إلى إظهار الحركة
لذلك عندما نقترب منها ،
فإنها ستتحرك نوعًا ما بعيدًا عن  بالطريقة التي
أخبرنا بها طيار مقاتل سابق آخر في البحرية ، ديفيد فريفور ، أنه رأى جسمًا غامضًا أثناء مهمة تدريبية
قبالة سان دييغو في عام 2004
في يوم صاف ، ما فاجأه أن
الجسم لم يكن لديه قوة دفع مرئية
وكان أكثر رشاقة بكثير من طائرة أو
طائرة هليكوبتر قال ذلك  بدا وكأنه لعبة
تك تاك طويلة بطول 40 قدمًا بدون أجنحة ، كان هذا
مفاجئًا للغاية مثل كرة بينج بونج ترتد
من الحائط وتضرب وتذهب في الاتجاه الآخر
وتغير الاتجاهات في  يقول أحد المصادر
إن المسؤولين الأمريكيين لا يمكنهم استبعاد
احتمال أن هذه الأجسام الغامضة
تم تشغيلها من قبل أعداء أمريكا مثل
روسيا والصين الذين يقولون إنهم يطورون
أسلحة تفوق سرعة الصوت ، فهل
نواجه أنظمة أسلحة صاروخية
من روسيا أو
الصين أفضل بكثير من  دفاعاتنا
موجودة ، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك ،
فلدينا طريق طويل لنقطعه لحماية
بلدنا
أو هل يمكن أن نواجه
كائنات فضائية
بالنسبة لي ، يبدو الأمر أرضيًا ولا
يبدو غريبًا إذا كان أي شيء يشبه الإنسان
على
الإطلاق هذا اختبار الرائحة الخاص بي  بالنسبة للأجانب ،
فماذا يفعل البشر؟
نحن نبني مركبات نصنع حرفًا نطير بها
في السماء